le drame s'est déroulé vers midi ce
mercredi suite à un différend de
voisinage
un homme demeurant au deuxième étage de
la résidence sainte hilaire à chalon a
ouvert le feu sur un couple et leur
fille habitant au 3e étage
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
il aurait ensuite mis le feu à son
appartement créant l'émoi dans
l'immeuble disons que j'étais sur mon
lieu de travail et puis ma fille
williams a donc téléphoné elle était un
peu catastrophé même très choquée elle
entendait des coups de feu ne savait pas
si des pompiers étaient là elles
voyaient des gendarmes qui étaient plus
ou moins vers les voitures ont pour
intervenir donc voilà donc moi j'ai
quitté mon travail ma fille la plus
jeune m'a rejoint
et puis on est venu tout de suite quoi
moi je suis arrivé à 13 heures parce que
ma soeur m'a appelé à midi en panique
elle a entendu des coups de feu y avait
le feu qui est vu qu'ils partaient donc
quand je suis arrivé avait de la fumée
qui sortait mais voilà moi j'ai rien vu
on a attendu sur le côté on ne pouvait
pas s'approcher donc voilà je ne sais
pas plus le bilan de cette altercation
et lourd selon nos informations le père
de famille aurait été touché
mortellement trois fois à la tête
son épouse aurait reçu quatre
projectiles dont un lors est grièvement
blessée au cou elle a été transporté en
hélicoptère à l'hôpital de dijon
sa fille âgée de 21 ans serait moins
grièvement blessée elle a été conduite
aux urgences de l'hôpital de chalon
le tireur un homme âgé de 75 ans se
serait suicidé après son forfait il
avait déjà fait l'objet d'une procédure
judiciaire en avril dernier pour avoir
menacé ces mêmes voisins avec un couteau
on ne connaît pas pour l'instant le
motif de cette dramatique querelle de
voisinage
en parallèle trois policiers et deux
pompiers ont été admis aux urgences
après avoir été incommodées par les
fumées du sinistre